[Music]
light is everywhere it allows us to
interpret the world around us and is a
crucial requirement for life on earth
but what is light this is one of the
fundamental questions of quantum physics
and even einstein had difficulty
wrapping his brain around it
hi i'm rich burnett for one dream in
this episode of perspectives three
scientists discuss groundbreaking
research that led to our current
understanding of the quantum world
we begin now in the early 19th century
with a famous experiment that provided
our earliest understanding of the true
nature of light enjoy
[Music]
what young did was to have two adjacent
slits in a screen with another screen
much further away
if light is a wave then what would
happen is that it would pass through the
two slits
the light passing through one slit would
spread out as it moves to the distant
screen
the same thing would happen to light
passing through the second screen
since you have two sources of waves
these two sets of waves can interfere
with one another
we say that the waves constructively
interfere if the two waves enhance one
another to make a bigger wave and they
destructively interfere if the two waves
cancel each other out
it takes a little math to work out where
the waves would constructively and
destructively interfere which i'll skip
i'll just show you what it looks like
if the slits are thin and placed close
to one another you can treat the point
between the two slits as the center and
what you see is that waves coming out at
certain angles constructively interfere
while other angles destructively
interfere you should note that there are
many angles for each
so what would you expect to see on the
distant screen
you'd expect to see bright spots where
the waves add together and dark spots
where they cancel
that's a clear prediction of wave theory
this is a clear difference in the
prediction of the behavior of what waves
would do and what particles would do
so what did young see
what he saw was a clear indication that
light was acting as a wave there is
really very very little wiggle room
from 1801 the scientific community
accepted that light was a wave
however
however
in the late 1800s a mystery arose
involving light and electrons
light carries energy you know that
because for example you can get a
sunburn which is when your skin is
damaged
moving to atoms you can think of
electrons as being held tightly to
atomic nuclei
in very crude terms they're like balls
tied to a post by a string
in that analogy the post is the nucleus
the ball is the electron and the string
is what holds the electron to the
nucleus
in our analogy if you bang into the ball
hard enough you can break the string and
the ball will fly away
similarly if you shine a bright light on
a material made of atoms it is possible
to knock off electrons this is called
the photoelectric effect and scientists
have known of this for nearly two
decades before it was explained
however when the photoelectric effect
was studied in detail there were some
mysteries specifically two features
the first is puzzling
certain colors of light will knock out
electrons and others won't
the exact color depends on the substance
but roughly speaking red orange yellow
and green just won't do it
blue purple and ultraviolet will
even at the time physicists knew that
different colors had different
wavelengths with the red orange and
yellow side having a long wavelength and
the blue indigo and violet side having a
short wavelength
and each material had a specific
wavelength above which electrons would
not be emitted and below which they
would
so that was a bit weird but it was
compounded by the fact that it didn't
matter how bright the light was that you
used the wavelength thing was the
barrier
you could really use really super bright
red light and you'd get no electron
emission
but use weak purple light and voila
electron emission and if you turned up
the brightness of purple light you'd get
more emission
now if light is a wave that's a weird
thing because the energy of a wave
depends on what physicists call its
amplitude or colloquially its brightness
it's kind of like waves on the beach
little wavelets don't do much damage but
get a six foot tall wave and they'll
knock you on your keister
and tsunamis with really high waves will
knock over buildings
the height or amplitude of the wave
governs its energy
so that's a weird thing
it means that in the photoelectric case
anyway light isn't acting like a wave
the situation was resolved in 1905 by
none other than albert einstein
einstein proposed that light came in
discrete lumps which is a fancy way to
say in particle form
the energy of each lump was proportional
to the frequency of light
frequencies inversely proportional to
wavelength so a long wavelength wave has
a low frequency while a short wavelength
light has a high frequency
thus the light on the blue indigo violet
light was high frequency which according
to einstein meant high energy
also let's think about what it means and
how the particle idea explains the data
if light is a particle and the energy of
the light is proportional to the
frequency then below some frequency the
individual particles of light what we
call photons just don't have enough
energy to knock out an electron
getting back to the analogy of a post
ball and string if you throw an object
at the ball and it doesn't have enough
energy it won't break the string
but any photon with higher frequency
which is to say higher energy will be
able to do so
so you can perhaps see why einstein's
idea was so powerful in fact it was his
explanation of the photoelectric effect
that netted them the nobel prize in
physics
it wasn't relativity
all right now we're in a pickle
thomas young proved quite convincingly
that light is a wave while einstein just
as convincingly showed that light was a
particle
light can't be both a wave and a
particle can it
and this gets even weirder
if einstein is right how can we explain
the young double slit experiment
to take another look at the young
experiment researchers tried a variant
of it
they started by just reproducing young's
interference result nothing had changed
in the intervening century
but then they turned down the intensity
of the light so low that only one photon
was emitted at a time and they shot the
light at a pair of slits and looked for
the photon on the distant screen
let's talk for a moment about what you
would expect for both the particle and
wave scenario
if light is a particle it would appear
at a specific spot on the screen like a
bullet hitting a wall
if light is a wave it would appear in
the wave pattern just very very faint
then photon after photon the pattern
would get brighter and brighter
so what did they see
they shot the first photon and it turned
out a drum roll please
it appeared as a single spot
it was like particle
but that's just totally weird since a
bright light on two slits resulted in
thomas young's wave pattern
so they continued their experiment and
they shot a second photon still detected
like a particle
okay then another and another and
another let's just fast forward and see
what the final result was
after millions and billions of photons
what they found was the wave pattern of
the double slit experiment
i wonder which way electrons behave
so let's rerun our experiment with the
electrons and let's add a way to keep
track of exactly which of the vertical
holes in the wall each electron goes
through
if they're really acting like particles
then we ought to see that as each
electron passes through one and only one
of those gaps
if they're acting like waves when they
get to the wall
well let's just see what happens
first we need some way to keep track of
which vertical gap each electron is
passing through
one way to do this is to put a light
source near each slit
that way if an electron passes through
say the gap on the left then that
electron ought to scatter some of the
light over there and we'll see a flash
near the gap on the left
we'll also need to leave some sort of
triggered camera next to each gap
something that will record a flash if it
happens
so now we've updated our measurement
taking devices
now when we send electrons toward the
wall with the two slits in it if an
electron passes through one gap or the
other our light sources with triggered
cameras will capture the event and
they'll tell us which gap the electron
passes through
and if the electron continues on its
path it'll then hit the back wall and
mark our strike paper
in this way we should be able to keep
track of everything we're interested in
all at the same time
so now imagine with this more
sophisticated setup sending electrons
toward the wall that has two slits in it
as we do so we'll see flashes of light
and we'll hear the camera click as each
electron passes through one hole in the
wall or the other that seems very
reasonable
well let's continue sending electrons in
that direction until we think we have
enough statistics to go ahead and check
what's going on at the back wall
so what do we find
well this is strange
after we sent through electrons we check
to see on the back wall and see that
everything has changed we've lost the
interference pattern on the back wall
now the pattern on the back wall looks
just as though we had sent tennis balls
through it the frustrating thing here is
that the very act of measuring and
keeping track of which opening each
electron went through destroyed the
interference effect
and it turns out that there's just no
way around this you might think oh we
just need to turn down the intensity of
the light source maybe we used light
that was too bright and it disturbed the
electrons too much
what you'll find as you turn the
intensity of the light down is that at
some point there won't be enough
intensity left to see the electrons
anymore and then just about the time
when the light is no longer bright
enough to tell you which electron went
through which opening
you'll recover the interference pattern
or you might think about changing the
color of the light instead of the
intensity
now since longer wavelength light
carries less energy
maybe it will disturb the electrons less
so let's try that what if we try
changing the wavelength of the light
used to measure which electron goes
through which opening
in this case we'll see that the same
types of limitations come up
if we make the wavelength longer and
longer hoping that that will disturb the
electron less and less we'll see that
when we reach a wavelength long enough
to recover the interference pattern on
the back wall
now we can no longer tell which of the
openings the electron went through
sure now we have our interference
pattern on the back wall again but at
these long wavelengths the flash we see
will be so diffuse and spread out that
we can't tell which gap the electron
went through
it really does seem like this is
something we are stuck with if we find a
way to measure which opening the
electron went through the interference
pattern is destroyed but as long as we
don't check on exactly how the electron
gets through the gaps in the first wall
there will be an interference pattern on
the back wall
these things really do act like
particles and like waves at the same
time
throughout the mid and late 1920s a
great deal of effort was directed toward
developing a rigorous system of
mathematics that could be used to
describe and calculate how quantum
particle waves behave and interact
in 1925 for example erwin schrodinger
developed an equation that describes the
wave-like behavior of electrons
the schrodinger equation is still taught
today to nearly all undergraduate
physics students and it makes accurate
predictions at least for electrons that
are moving at speeds far below the speed
of light
and schrodinger wasn't by any means the
only scientist to make progress in this
direction
many other physicists including paul
dirac and werner heisenberg and max
bourne each made important contributions
around the same time
this new generation of quantum theorists
was not content with the old quantum
theory as developed by einstein bohr and
de broly
they were intent on building a more
complete and more mathematically robust
system
this system would become known as
quantum mechanics
as this system of quantum mechanics was
being developed
einstein found himself more and more
troubled by its implications
at least with the concept of light
quanta there was some notion of what it
meant for light to be a wave
it had been long established that light
consists of oscillating or vibrating
electric and magnetic fields
and the peaks of a light wave
are those points in space where the
electric and magnetic fields are the
strongest
but when it came to something like an
electron wave it wasn't at all clear
what the peaks of the wave really
represented
the key question about matter waves and
the question that was bothering einstein
was the following
what exactly is waving
a classical wave makes sense because
it's made up of many objects a water
wave for example is the highest at one
point because there are the most water
molecules at that point
but the wave of a single electron can't
be interpreted in terms of the
collective behavior of many objects it's
only one electron after all
one object can't exhibit the kind of
collective behavior that a water wave
does
in 1926 max born proposed a very radical
answer to this essential question
bourne argued that the shape of the wave
of an electron or of any other quantum
object called the wave function
should be interpreted to represent the
probability of that object being found
in a given location when or if it were
measured
if you conduct an experiment to
determine the location of a given
electron
there's a high probability that you'll
find it somewhere where the absolute
value of the wave function is very high
there's a much lower probability that
you'll find it in a place where the
absolute absolute value of the wave
function is low
as bourne saw the problem there's no
choice but to view the wave of an
electron in terms of the probability of
it being found in a particular location
or in a particular configuration
and this soon became the standard way
for physicists to think about matter
waves and quantum mechanics
let's take a second to step back and ask
what this really means
according to born in his way of thinking
about quantum mechanics how should we
think about the electron
as it exists prior to being measured
well in some sense according to born the
electron is extended across the volume
of space that is covered by the wave
function
when we measure the location of an
electron
it's always point like without any
spatial extent
but before it is measured an electron is
simultaneously in all the locations it's
covered by its wave function it's in
many places and all at the same time
in this sense electrons and other
quantum objects have a kind of
probabilistic existence
being in all possible places and doing
all possible things at all possible
times
this is sometimes described in terms of
what is known as the heisenberg
uncertainty principle
according this principle the more
precisely defined the location of a
quantum object is the less specified is
its velocity and vice versa
according to quantum mechanics an object
cannot be in only one place and moving
at only one speed
at this point in time you're probably
feeling a bit confused and you should be
this is bizarre and incredibly
counter-intuitive stuff
quantum mechanics describes a kind of
existence that is beyond strange
and is fundamentally different from
anything that we as human beings
normally we normally experience
as niels bohr once famously remarked
anyone who is not shocked by quantum
theory has not understood it
in december of 1926 einstein wrote a
letter to max born expressing his
skepticism of the new interpretation of
quantum theory
in this letter einstein made one of the
most famous and often quoted remarks
let me read you just a few sentences
from this letter
quantum mechanics is very impressive
but an inner voice tells me that it's
not yet the real thing
the theory says a lot but does not bring
us any closer to the secret of the old
one
i at any rate am convinced that he does
not play dice
einstein expressed sentiment similar to
this one on many occasions throughout
his life
in various ways einstein became fond of
insisting that god does not play dice
with the universe
in the late 1920s a consensus was
starting to form around a refined
version of max borne's interpretation
this view became known as the copenhagen
interpretation named for the city where
niels bohr werner heisenberg and others
had made major contributions to its
development
according to the copenhagen view of
quantum mechanics quantum particles
behave like waves
these particle waves are each described
by their wave function the shape of a
given particle's wave function
represents the probability that it will
be found at different locations or with
different velocities
generally speaking quantum particles
exist in multiple locations at once and
have multiple velocities all
simultaneously
but according to the copenhagen
interpretation whenever an observation
of a particle is made its wave function
collapses
and the measured quantity takes on a
single measured value
at the 1927 sol conference it became
clear that a consensus view was starting
to form around the copenhagen
interpretation
most of those in attendance seemed to
have accepted the probabilistic nature
of their new theory
furthermore there was a general
acceptance that this was likely to be a
real aspect of nature and not something
that would be explained away when they
better understood the problem
for example max born werner heisenberg
and niels bohr were each fully aware
that the universe is described by
quantum mechanics was fundamentally
probabilistic
and while they acknowledged that there
was still some chance that determinism
could somehow be restored in some future
revision of the theory they each thought
that this was pretty unlikely
unlike einstein they were prepared to
accept the lack of determinism in the
subatomic world
einstein was unwilling to accept any
version of quantum mechanics in which
god played dice with the universe
and when einstein declared this niels
bohr simply replied by telling einstein
to stop telling god what to do
hey thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about the topics in this
episode the full list of series that
these clips came from is in the
description below you can watch them all
on one dream and don't forget to
subscribe to this youtube channel for
new episodes of perspectives and you can
watch previous ones here